[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: I'm head of the
game service AI division.
And at the same time, head
of technical technical
[INAUDIBLE], Netmarble.
Yes, and I-- frankly, this is
a little bit [INAUDIBLE] for me
because believe
me or not, I'm one
of a popular speaker in Korea.
And I believe I do a very
good speech in Korean.
But I have to speak
in English now--
very nervous-- and I frankly
tried to cancel this session
several times--
[LAUGHTER]
--because I just use this
event to question my developer
to develop on time my
product, company product.
And I said, yeah, I have to
do some speech in USA so you
have to beat the schedule.
And I just forgot to cancel
it a little bit earlier.
Last week, I tried to call
to head of the [? API ?]
at Google Cloud.
And I said, I'm not happy, and
I want to cancel this project,
and I want to cancel this event.
And they said, why?
And your name is already
printed out everywhere,
and you have to do that.
And I said, oh,
no, no, no, no, no.
My presentation
is not so popular.
There is nobody that
wants to attend it.
But so many guys here.
Yeah, thank you for
joining this event.
And yes.
So I spent maybe three days--
three whole days to
prepare the material
to share my experience
over [? GGP, ?]
and also, my pleasant
memory with Google PSO.
But before we do
that, I just want
to introduce Netmarble to you.
To you familiar to
Netmarble, Netmarble
is a very big game company.
But in Korea, number one.
But in USA, I think everybody
just know Kabam or Jam City.
That is our branch.
We acquired their companies.
But Netmarble is not
so popular, so I really
want to introduce Netmarble.
Then I will explain
what kind of thing
we are doing for AI and
the machine learning.
Then I just want to
share what we did
and deep dive some case
study for maybe three
cases I prepared.
Yes, this is Netmarble.
It's our logo.
And this is our main characters.
The name is Kuku.
It's something like [INAUDIBLE]
when you are smiling.
And believe it or not,
this is a dinosaur.
Our chairman said,
that is a dinosaur.
But yeah, looks like a
little bit crocodile.
But anyway, that is a dinosaur.
Yellow color is
our symbol color.
And this is show our key
titles from "Marvel,"
"Transformer," and "Lineage
II" and "StoneAge M"
and "Seven Nights" and
Everybody's Marble."
This is our key titles--
our paper.
Still nervous.
Yeah, we are using
our external IP
to our latest marketing cost.
So why we follow
"Marvel" from Disney
and maybe "Transformer"
from Hasbro.
And at the same time, we try
to make our own strong IP.
The "Seven Nights," the center,
this one is our original IP.
And we bought "Stone Age."
And this is a [INAUDIBLE]
model, "Everybody's Marble,"
and that is also
our original IP.
And this one is "Lineage ll"--
one of our very
popular MMORPG IP.
And we borrow that from NCsoft.
And we make a huge
success in Korea.
And maybe-- I don't know--
everybody see that TBCF.
We are using Conan O'Brien for
marketing this title in USA.
But we expecting a huge success
in USA, but not so much.
We just try, but failed.
Anyway, we try our best to make
a more bigger success in USA.
This is our history.
Netmarble is not
a young company.
Netmarble was founded in 2000.
And we are doing a RPG game
developer and also a publisher.
And we changed the whole
direction in 2013 from RPG
to mobile.
And we succeed there and we are
continuously growing so fast.
We have a partnership with
Tencent and [? EngiSoft. ?]
And we acquired the Jam City,
and we acquired the Kabam.
And we are going to be going
bigger with innovation.
For example, this title's
name is "ChaChaCha."
This is the first [INAUDIBLE]
mega hit game in Korea.
And this is [? monster ?]
[? taming. ?] And we make
a standard over
mobile RPG in Korea.
And also, we try to
real time [? build ?]
with the [INAUDIBLE] model,
"Everybody's Marble."
And this is a phenomenal
[INAUDIBLE],, a huge success.
In this period, our market
share in Korea is over 50%.
It's crazy.
And then, we launched
"Lineage Revolution."
We expect a more
hardcore title will
be popular in our mobile
scene, so we launched MMORPG.
And those also make
a huge success.
Then we acquired
Kabam and the Jam City
to crack in the USA market.
We are Korean so it's really
hard to understand what
Western guys love, so
we just find ourselves
a simple solution using money.
OK, some company.
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
Yes.
This is our 11-year
growing graph.
It's crazy, right?
And we maintain this slope
continuously these days too.
And we-- Last year, we
are number three publisher
combining Apple and Google.
And only for Google, we are
number one, as far as I know.
It's [INAUDIBLE], right?
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
This is numbers.
We are very proud of that.
And we are number three
game publisher globally.
And 11-year CAGR is 89%
and $68 billion MAU.
It's bigger than Korean
total population.
And we have 19 independent
development studios.
And we have over 3,000
developers in Korea.
Maybe we are over 3,500, right?
[INAUDIBLE]
It is growing up very fast.
And the funny thing is,
we just have only 4%
global market share
on mobile sales.
We are expecting maybe going
faster, maybe 5 or 6 and 10.
And my chairman is always
pushing us to get more market
share globally.
And then, the mobile
in the global market
is very high place
all over the world.
And in China, we didn't
have any business
yet because Korea
and China government
has sort of a political issue.
And it's really hard
to enter China market.
But I think we can enter
China market maybe this year.
We are expecting that.
And that will make a more
bigger growth this year.
And Korea is still the
number one market for us.
But number two is
in North America,
and number three is Japan.
And we are focusing
on Japanese market
this year to be
number one in Japan.
So yesterday, we
launched a new title--
"The King of Fighters
Allstar" yesterday,
and it looks like
a very good start.
Yes.
This is our studio's chart.
And I want to show
you this because we
have so many studios.
That means we have our
[INAUDIBLE] pipeline to develop
many flagship titles.
That makes us do business
very aggressively.
For example, last week,
we launched "StoneAge M,"
and this week, we launched
"The King of Fighters Allstar."
Next month, we will be launching
new title maybe in Korea.
Next, next month, also, we
launch new title somewhere.
We are aggressively
launching titles.
Thank you.
So what are we doing with
artificial intelligence
and machine learning?
So I just want to explain
Netmarble's uniqueness.
We are leading mobile game
publisher from PC to mobile.
And we still have
a small PC business
and, yeah, going to mobile.
And at the same time, we are
not focusing on the one genre.
We are doing some casual games.
And at the same time, we
still develop our action RPG.
And these days, we are
developing our MMORPG
for making more bigger money.
But still, we are sorting
our new genre [INAUDIBLE]
to grow up more faster.
I think there is
a big difference
between us and the other
mobile game companies.
Usually, general
company just focuses
on one genre or one title.
But we do various genres
for various targets,
from casual user to hardcore,
and from simple game,
simple project game to MMORPG.
We developed every
kind of title.
And we are working for many
countries and for the world--
"Seven Nights," "Marble
Future Fight," "Lineage ll,"
"King of Fighter Allstar."
We are making a huge success in
Korea, Southeast Asia and Japan
and also United States--
we are expecting more.
To do that, we do many
things, especially, we
are making various attempts
to [? enter ?] [INAUDIBLE]
mobile game operation
in marketing.
In Korea, we define what is
best mobile game best marketing.
That means we use all
kinds of a media channels,
including TV and online and
billboard for two weeks.
We spend crazy money
only for two weeks.
And they'll make
us our branding.
Then, huge success.
There is a simple formula
in Korea for making
huge money with a mobile title.
We define that.
And also, at the same time,
we test other [INAUDIBLE]
global marketing trend.
For example,
performance marketing.
In Korea, performance
marketing is not so important.
As I said, mass marketing
dominate the market,
mobile game market.
So general, Korean companies
isn't familiar to performance
marketing.
In here, performance
marketing is major,
and maybe a TV commercial
or a billboard is not major.
Why?
I don't know.
Looks like.
But in Korea, we are collecting
all kinds of information
about best marketing.
And outside of Korea, we are
adopting performance marketing
trend.
And also, in Japan, Japan
is a very, very unique place
that is very, very
hard to understand
why this kind of
method is working,
and why this is not working.
It's really, really
hard to understand.
But we try to make success in
Japan during several years,
and we're collecting all
kinds of information.
And we finally, we
obtained [INAUDIBLE]..
Now, we believe we almost
have the same ability
as a Japanese company.
So Netmarble's strength
for AI and machine learning
will be various best data
and operation know-how.
We have various genre
data, various markets,
various marketing method,
various operations--
casual to hardcore, from Asia
to Europe and North America,
performance marketing
based on mass data,
and fast [? adoption ?] to
Japan marketing specialty,
and maintaining flagship title
inside of the top 10 revenue
chart over five years.
We are collecting that kind
of data for five years.
That is our special
weapon that we
believe there is a key
difference between Netmarble
and other game companies.
But that kind of
data is important.
I think that it's important,
because [INAUDIBLE] title
usually enjoying methods
that [? just ?] [? are ?]
[? working, ?] right?
[? Conquer ?] and
[? consider ?] ending.
Mobile game is quite different.
It's free to play to
maximize exposure.
At the same time, we
prefer all kinds of content
to maintain retention
rate, high retention rate.
Somebody really
love competition.
Somebody really love community.
Somebody really
love challenging.
Somebody really love power.
So we prepare every kind
of content in our one title
to maximize our
success possibility.
That is Netmarble's way.
So this blue shape is Korea,
and this is a Brussels,
and this is USA, Taiwan.
Same title, same balance,
one build, but every country
enjoys that in different ways.
It's really, really funny.
And this is a time axis.
And this is a number that
[? try ?] [? to ?] enjoy
the content.
Blue one is Korea and
purple one is USA--
huge difference.
The easiest way to conquer or
be number one at some title,
there is some most
efficient way [INAUDIBLE]..
But anyway, US guys
play differently,
Korean guys play differently.
Everybody's differently.
We have the kind
of in-game data,
I believe it's a really, really,
really powerful weapon for us.
But problem is, we have a
huge legacy of our publishing
business from the PC side.
So that is why we have a very
good relationship with Google
Cloud.
And now, we hope to change
our legacy to a cloud trend
as soon as possible.
And we need huge help
from maybe Google PSO.
[LAUGHS]
So because of the [INAUDIBLE]
transition from PC to mobile--
there are so many legacies
on the PC game side
and the games [INAUDIBLE] last
year [INAUDIBLE] for cloud.
And also, our analytics
is [INAUDIBLE] for mobile.
Are we are changing everything
as soon as possible.
And I think if we can
change our platform
to a public cloud
like Google GCP,
and if we can combine everything
with the data we have,
I think we can be very strong
AI and machine learning company
maybe, can be.
So Netmarble launched the
NARC earlier this year
to develop new business, new
AI business with this data
and our operation know-how.
I know NARC means a little bit
drug-related thing in here.
But I said, I don't
use this name.
But anyway, my chairman
decided to use this one.
NARC means Netmarble
AI Revolution Center.
And revolution is our
key word for marketing.
And we hire Juhnyoung Lee.
17 years-- he works at IBM
T.J. Watson Research Center.
And he is maybe one of
our fathers of Watson.
And everybody hate
Watson anyway.
Juhnyoung Lee is currently
the head of NARC,
and at the same time,
CTO of Netmarble.
He is leading every
change at technical side.
Our industry [INAUDIBLE]
be very simple.
We have to make game development
using an AI technique.
And we want to
make a more better
operation with AI solutions.
Yes.
This [INAUDIBLE] said,
we can do everything.
We will do everything.
But yeah, we already
make some progress
at reinforcement learning.
Everybody tried
that, but we tried
reinforcement learning to
solve our balancing problems.
And also, we are making a game
simulator to use AI technique.
And at the same time, we are
doing some big data analysis
on Google Cloud platform
GCP with BigQuery
And they use our
action data, and they
use our profile data, QA
automation system-- that
kind of thing we are doing now.
I take charge of this
side, not this side.
Yeah.
As I said, I'm in charge
over game service AI--
AI related to game operations,
all kinds of activity,
not outside of a game.
For example, marketing
and operation and also,
big data analysis.
Yes, so I make us
a simple strategy--
just the ABC.
I want to provide actionable
insight to everybody inside
of Netmarble.
I don't know.
Many game studios try
to prediction, right,
churn prediction, LTV
prediction, many things.
But is that kind of thing
actually meaningful,
is my question.
For many years, we tried to
copy the Western company.
The Western company looks
like higher than our ability.
So we tried to
catch up everything.
So we try to predict churn.
We tried to predict the LTV.
And our conclusion is, yes,
we can do that, but so what?
So what we can do to make more
money or make a better service
is not the question.
So these days, our
team is focusing
on making actionable insight--
deliver actionable insight to
everybody inside of Netmarble.
For example, we give sort
of a simple loss prediction
reporterd to the marketer.
You can decide
everything based on data,
and the marketer can decide--
more money I will spend, or
stop spending, or changing
a marketing channel.
And every day, they are
trying to optimize everything
based on data.
That kind of thing, I
really want to do that.
And business impact.
AI and machine learning is
a very, very trendy tech,
and it can solve many problems.
But for me, solving technical
problems is not attractive.
We really want to
solve simple problems,
but that has a huge
business impact.
For example, we develop the
ad fraud detecting system.
That will save huge money
for performance marketing.
And that kind of thing,
I really want to do that.
At the same time, Netmarble
is a mobile game company.
That means we don't have
very good developers,
strong development tower
over AI or machine learning.
To solve that problem, we
really tried collaboration
with the other big companies.
For example, we have a
very good relationship
with Google Cloud-- a PSO team.
PSO team provided
many insights to us
to give develop a new system
and solve our headache problems.
They are very smart, and we
are catching up their ability.
But one more thing is, we
tried to solve right problem.
The right problem is something
we really want to solve.
And that is, human can
solve, but sometimes need
a lot of people and it
takes a lot of time.
That kind of problem
is perfect, perfect
for using machine
learning, we believe.
And we already
tried several cases
and make ourself a
[INAUDIBLE] chart.
So cases-- for marketing,
we do LTV prediction,
ROAS prediction, and ad
fraud detection system.
And as I said, we
developed LTV prediction,
but nobody is using that
because it's a little bit
hard to use for mass marketing.
And in Korea, LTV
is not so important.
And that is also the same in
Southeast Asia and maybe Japan.
So we developed ROAS prediction.
And we can recoup our
marketing budget--
monthly base.
We predict our
marketing budget will
be [? liquid ?] in two months
or three months later or four
months later.
And then, we
developed the system.
And the [INAUDIBLE]
is very, very high.
Currently, it's--
how can I say--
maybe plus or minus 15 days.
It's really, really accurate.
And our boss always
decide to spend more money
based on a loss prediction.
And also, we developed ad
fraud detection system.
That is a headache
for many marketers.
And it's really, really--
there are so many solutions.
For example, [INAUDIBLE] also
provides that kind of thing.
And many [? trending ?]
companies
provide some solution
to detect ad fraud.
Problem is, we don't want to
rely on outside of the company.
And we believe we have
plenty of data to detect
ad fraud by ourselves.
And we tried and we're
making huge success.
For game service operation,
we developed churn report,
like every other guys.
But we use machine
learning to find out
the difference between
leaving or staying.
You just find what kind
of difference they have.
Somebody leaving after
enjoying some [? PVP ?] loss.
And somebody staying longer if
they played five or six times
a day.
That kind of insight we
want to extract from data.
And every morning, our operation
team members get a report--
what kind of trend is going on
and what kind of key difference
between a churn [INAUDIBLE]
and staying [INAUDIBLE]..
And also, we developed a
special churn prediction report.
We are focusing on giving
us some clue for action.
For example, yeah,
here's somebody,
and their churn probability
is maybe over 90%.
That means we can't do anything.
He will go out, and he
will enjoy the other title.
And somebody here in
the churn prediction
will maybe a churn
rate, maybe 60% or 80%.
But our second day
retention is over 50%.
So 60% is higher or not?
It's really, really hard to
understand for daily operation
guides.
So we just give ourselves
a simple guideline.
Just focusing on this guy and
if you can hold this guy maybe
the day after tomorrow, you
can get some huge retention
in [? three ?] [? months. ?]
That kind of report,
we deliver every day.
And also, we develop
in-game anomaly detection.
And then, that is our
collaboration project
with Google PSO team.
This day, our title
service period
is longer longer and longer.
That means, content
is very, very complex.
It is really hard to
maintain bug free status.
There will always be a bug.
That means there is
always bug [INAUDIBLE]..
How to find that kind of
user as soon as possible?
That is one of the
most important problem
to service a longer
and longer and longer.
So we developed test systems.
So I want to deep
dive three cases.
One is Resemara Report.
Do you know Resemara?
That one you know, right?
Yeah, you are from Japan?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER: Yes.
Resemara is a very,
very interesting way
to enjoy game content.
Resemara is, reset,
combine, marathon.
In Japan and in
Asia, usually, free
to play game adopting
[INAUDIBLE] business model.
[INAUDIBLE] means,
how can I say it?
[INAUDIBLE] yeah, are you
familiar to [INAUDIBLE]??
Something like a
lock box, right?
And in Japan, marketing prices
are really, really high.
That means, we want to hold the
user at least one hour a day.
That means, we had to give
sort of a very good impression
at the launching time.
So we prepared some special
[INAUDIBLE] box only
for new users.
It contains something
like a very special card,
or a very special character,
or a very special gift.
To get that, user
reset, that means
delete the app and reinstall
app continuously for maybe two
or three days without stopping.
Usually, maybe 200
times or 300 times, user
can get actually what they want.
For some time, it's over
1,000 or 2000 times.
It looks very stupid, but
anyway, they tried that.
And that is also one
of the main methods
to enjoy the game in Japan
and in Southeast Asia.
Problem is, can't
trust every KPI.
Retention is a very low.
That is because of Resemara.
Nobody knows that.
And first, a sign-up
gift is good enough.
Nobody knows that.
But something like
Resemara is too high.
That means we give too good gift
to a [? sign ?] [? user. ?] But
if the Resemara is
too small number,
that means it's not good enough.
And how many account
transitions happened?
That is also a very
important thing.
Something like this
title is very good,
and this title gives us a
very special sign-up gift.
And then, they do a Resemara.
And there are some in China,
at this kind of situation,
they make a Resemara
[? pump ?] to get
themself a special account.
And then, generating so
many accounts and sell that
to Japan actual player.
And that kind of thing can
break the balance of the game.
So it's a very, very
dangerous thing.
So we make Resemara report
system using many Google Cloud
Platform services.
We are not using machine
learning or some special thing.
But anyway, you can analyze
every user local data
in real time,
because of BigQuery
and the powerful
Google Cloud platform.
So finally, we can generate a
trustful KPI without Resemara.
This is very important.
We developed a thing
maybe last week--
that is, I pushed my
developers to prepare "King
of Fighter Allstar" launching.
Ad fraud system.
To explain how ad fraud
is a headache for me,
I just searched Google and
found some very simple articles
about that.
Mobile ad spending is growing
another 20% this year.
And 20% [INAUDIBLE].
Every title has ad fraud.
That means the illegal
downloads or something
like a clicking [? palm ?] or
something like [INAUDIBLE],,
just to get money without
installing, or stealing
installs from others.
That kind of thing is happening
again and again and again.
This makes a large problem.
That means they will
not enjoy our title,
and that we spend money, and
that their retention will
be going down.
Problem is, without ad
fraud, actual retention
will be a little more higher.
That means we have to spend our
money to a more bigger success.
But because of ad fraud,
we can't decide something
like a right--
we can't make a right decision.
So we developed ad
fraud detection system.
And I will explain
how we detect that.
First, we create cohort.
Then we create
cohort-specific variable.
And we calculate normal
range by every variable.
We maintain [INAUDIBLE]
ad channels,
something like, for
example, Facebook.
Facebook is really hard to
make something like ad fraud.
So that kind of data we are
collecting now and comparing
untrustful [? trapping. ?]
This kind of cohort is a
little bit strange, right?
Everybody looks like this one,
but here, [INAUDIBLE] this one.
We give some of the
report to a marketer.
And the marketer check,
deep dive, and find out this
is something like a [INAUDIBLE].
Yep, this is a diagram.
Funny thing is, this is
also a very simple trick
to get our money
from us, something
like click [INAUDIBLE].
That kind of thing,
still it could
just-- so we developed
one more [? loot. ?]
Just comparing to
stand out in others,
and also checking
out the simple rules.
For example, just
to log-in same time,
and just to log-out
same time, just
try to [INAUDIBLE]
at the same time,
that kind of a simple click bot,
we can find with simple rules.
And the last is in-game
anomaly detection.
Yes?
It's all there.
This is human lying
down in the head font.
It's funny.
But it's an expression
of something like angry,
because of some bug,
or some [INAUDIBLE],,
or some operation
fault. In Korea,
the user is angry
about that, and making
something like this kind
of article, [KOREAN]..
It means lie down.
And that kind of thing is a
very, very dangerous for us,
because it makes some bad
branding for our title.
And then, to prevent
this kind of thing,
we have to find out
bug or [INAUDIBLE]
as soon as possible.
So we developed the
rule-based engine.
The problem is, every month,
we provide new content.
That means every month, we
have to prepare new rule
to detect bug or [INAUDIBLE].
That is almost impossible,
because it's too complex,
and then nobody cares
about this system.
They just want to focus
on developing new content.
They don't want to
make a new design rule.
So rule-based engine
cannot solve our problems.
So we are erecting
a LSTM AutoEncoder
Network to solve this problem.
And what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Because it was most
effective [INAUDIBLE]
for analyzing the user
behavior by sequence
and then filtering
the [? onliner. ?]
These complex
activities we developed.
We use every kind
of digital service.
And then, we control
that using our Jenkins.
And we do sort of
a segment approach.
That [INAUDIBLE] EDA.
How do we manage in that?
We report the abnormally
detected results
to the operation
part every hour.
And people at the operator check
the game inside that situation.
And then, if there is
something like a bug,
reporting to developers.
The developer fixes
that, and we just
[? ban ?] the bug
[INAUDIBLE] every hour.
So that is our current vision.
So summary-- I don't want
to try this one again.
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
Netmarble has been
utilizing machine
learning one by one for the
area that needs a lot of people
to work on and
requires a lot of time.
And some problems have
a big business impact.
There are many things to
do in the future, but yeah.
I believe with the collaboration
with Google Cloud and the PSO
team, we can solve as many
problems as soon as possible.
We will try that continuously.
I believe next year maybe
we can provide more insight
for a case to everybody.
And that time, I think
I will hire something
like English speaking,
English native person
to do some speech for
me, instead of me.
[LAUGHS] Thank you.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
And we don't prepare any Q&A.
But anyway, these three guys
that are wearing the same
t-shirts, that means they
are an actual developer.
I'm just pushing them to
make this kind of a result.
And they know what kind
of product they made.
That means, you can ask
any kind of question,
for example, why you are
using [? LTV, ?] and if that's
really helpful or not.
That kind of question, you
could ask for them, not for me.
[LAUGHS] Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]